for most people valentine's day probably
means some combination of flowers and
candy maybe a dinner date but here at
cbs mornings we wanted to take a closer
look at love and its many meanings so we
sent our contributor jamie wax to talk
to an esteemed group of experts very
intuitive group you got here uh
natural-born experts you might call them
and he's here to share their insights
insights now jamie good morning good
morning tony that's true it is said that
love makes us all feel like kids again
so our experts in this case are second
graders at laylee elementary school in
naples florida we wanted to know all
their thoughts on love and began by
asking the big question we all ponder at
some point what is love
[Music]
love is like
it's where
you really like somebody
and your heart
really wants to be with them love
is to me
is
helping others
caring
respecting love is family i don't know
how to explain it that much hugging
liking and loving people
why is love important
um
my dad loves me my mom loves me my
brother sometimes hits me but still he
loves me
because
um
is love important yes and why do you
think
because um
it gives you your joy love is important
because if
we didn't have love then there wouldn't
be as much people in this world who's
the perfect person for you that you'd
want to grow old with
they had to like what i like they love
me for me what does that mean exactly
it means
that they don't want me to change for
who i am
what about when grown-ups talk about
romance what is romance
in movies it's like somebody kisses they
always kiss like on the lips or like
so for some reason they always kiss like
with their tongue and lips
in movies um
i see they don't just like like kiss for
one second they kiss for a long time
it's too long right yeah and then i'm
like i'm going in my room my parents
don't even kiss they don't kiss no thank
you for saying never
[Music]
when you're 16 you can like marry
someone when you're 16
yeah you think that's a good age to get
married yeah are you going to get
married when you're 16. yeah my mom says
i can't be married because i'm seven do
you want to get married of course i want
to get married how old do you want to be
when you get married
17. have you ever been in love with
anybody um i did have a boyfriend i
can't believe i had a boyfriend when i
was seven what would you do on a date
um i would go somewhere really good like
to a good restaurant you can just go
somewhere like a really good
store or what's a good store to take
someone to on a date walmart
[Music]
valentine's day is um
to show people how much you love them
let me teach you how to draw teach me
how to draw a heart
uh-huh
yeah
that's about caring about other people
love
being nice to other people
giving things the best gift i ever got
was being loved
[Applause]
i mean come on love experts no you
didn't get a word in it and it's it's so
good for mark and katie to know that
walmart is on the table
so i actually completely agree with
walmart as a daily location you can walk
for miles there's all kinds of
conversation pieces you know you can
have really important pre-marital
conversations like what kind of towels
do you want would you like these towels
or those two it's a good test spot no
no but okay all right
all right smart guy
how do you define love uh i mean i
define love as something indefinable but
i will tell you that i felt it at that
school in naples florida
and one of the most powerful things they
all said was that i asked them is there
too little love in the world does the
world need more love to a child they all
said no they thought about it it's a
beautiful sign of as divisive as we feel
this world is our children maybe don't
feel as awful about it as we think they
well it seems like there's a problem
then with the love pipeline a lot of
love in elementary school then something
happens when everybody grows up yeah
yeah we got to keep the love going
that's the key
was there anything that they they
thought that surprised you that they
said everything i mean i expected them
to be grossed out by kissing uh some of
them said some things about their
parents we did not air oh yeah
i like no we tried to be kind
all right so funny sammy and we'll leave
it there thank you so much thank you